I was gonna ask my pal today we're gonna
play finally through the victors of the
Indies vs. PewDiePie challenge challenge
what the [ __ ] did I call it
it was a game jab beep beep yeah I swear
I wasn't trying to hurt him
before I begin I said it before in
another video but I'm just so humbled by
everyone partaking in this thing the
promise was that I was gonna play the
top 10 rated games which we have here
but I figured why stop there so I'll
probably do more cuz there's 800 games
out there let's play we're gonna start
with the game that came in number 10
phobophobia does that mean we have a
phobia against phobias a game about
identifying people with phobias oh this
should be interesting
this is cool what is in this box though
a key aha sorry I'll never do that again
objective identify 4 party goers by
their phobias hey hey what a great party
it looks like Lisa isn't enjoying
yourself hey Lisa you made it mmm you
look fabulous today that's a great
carrot nose as always alright find the
person afraid of computers how do I
identify oh my god this is so strange
find the person afraid of their own body
that must be Lisa arachnophobia that
spiders I didn't read it I promise the
picture must be whoever scared of
himself he likes it don't do it
yeah that's right everyone will see how
lucky you are Lisa hey hey yeah I'm so
mean they have a phobia and I just keep
spamming ha ha I'm a horrible person
alright second but pictures nice angle
that's what I'm talking about
ha ha ha
poor poor soul that's right he doesn't
like space in his face Oh spider yes
now who who doesn't like a good little
spot
it's spider-man yeah that's oh it's in
his face now I'm so sorry
actually I'm not it's my job literally I
gotta eat it what the [ __ ] oh my god
poor guy I can't read yet I wasted it am
awaited vampires is that a Twilight
reference we're missing one of the
phobias there we go go to the hall to
exit
I am successfully a terrible person whoa
and it ends okay that's awesome
I like that one Thank You Cory game
mix-up is it's raining monkeys by Havana
24 oh my god it's raining monkeys you're
right move mails for umbrella Oh Mikey
what do I do
it's raining monkeys and we need you to
close all the pipes use your powerful
gadget all right sorry I'm so sorry why
would the rain monkeys why'd of all
ungodly things with a rain monkey oh my
god in my empanada man I know monkeys
are part of loominatee now it says been
confirmed how do I get there
wow that jump bro I'm Mary [ __ ]
Poppins [ __ ] oh god damn the monkeys
maybe we again there's no escape what a
genius idea of a game why has no one
thought of this before this will change
the entire gaming industry oh I have to
balance super monkey up there that's
that's game play I like it it was quick
it was short
kind of like my experience when I poop
nothing else all right Thank You Allah
I like your game
next up we have roadkill by Sean Beck
judging by the title this should be
pretty interesting Sean Beck wants you
to follow you on twitter but Sean you
haven't even asked the Senate date yet
first all right
run over pedestrians to score points
kill the streaker Jay extend your time
oh there's the streaker
gallop gallop damn it I missed well
where's the next streaker
oh god I'm killing so many people this
is wonderful is this like a cute version
of GTA oh Jesus Christ
yeah a kid-friendly GTA I love it okay
get the streaker how dare you be naked
there you go
ten seconds thank you streaker dick look
at that guy flew oh my god another
suitcase
oh god that sneaky pair aah aah
15 all right let's try and beat that
again it's never been this relaxing to
murder people I love it
just what I need it to deal with all the
[ __ ] Thanks Oh
hopefully [ __ ] okay my precious car
beep beep yeah I swear I wasn't trying
to hurt him whoa what I get what I got
26 all right let's see if you can beat
that price let's see if you can beat
that
it's wonderful to murder people I love
it so far it's been awesome game oh this
looks actually [ __ ] that that looks
cool it's made by funnies elector Oh God
oh well what what how do I even haha
what is happening oh my god somebody
predict tails
I think I'm killing people yep that's it
I'm killing them goodbye I'm Kelly Jan
tell my pugs I loved him
except Edgar I hate that son of a [ __ ]
yeah game over you own two dogs this is
pretty epic I just wish I wasn't so
terrible at it why he has to be so mean
whoa so if I kill someone I get my
health back okay that's cool I wanna be
I I wonder if I can crash into others
damn I should probably shouldn't try
I'll get I'm dying come on whoa hey
damnit what my how many our dogs are
down I would eat dogs I didn't know this
I'm travel G pro for it look at this
hahaha whoa take that Neji skinbag
I don't know if you're Nancy scare bags
but I like to think you are you're
probably really nice once we get to know
each other I actually probably should
feel bad but I don't know it looks like
pony Pie flies away again look I'm
getting kills I got three kills while I
died what was my score ah man I got like
20 I swear to god I'm not lying I got 20
I swear I swear all right that's a cool
game I like it
fun still electro made it great job
working our way to the top puppet their
police made by rivers mine cool name
cooler than friggin happy to pull us I
better pull s pump it up and let's pump
it up unless pop a little less
I'll put it four legs but somebody
played a blast I should be a song it is
now pump it up or less and put it flat
pick up your gun move by dragging five
notes around this is how I walk into the
club this is how we do it
kick that gun that's right how dare you
just do that [ __ ] gun what is with my
face should I be scared I think yes but
you can't have a face without some
sacrifice if you know what I made nice
split wow you got quite hey hey wait am
I going where are you going man come on
come on now muffuletta police prepare
the police Papa Papa Papa Papa Papa the
police who hired me as a cop seriously
all right here we go just got the gun I
picked it up with my left hand but it's
in my right hand I guess I'm Oh Papa the
police but sorry okay well done shoot
all the bottles that's right take that
box yay whoa welcome to Compton mother
damn it
reload weapon with magazine in your
other hand cool
yeah that's pretty badass alright there
we go oh I did miss the bottle
haha that was awesome you're the new
hope for robotic police officers now go
and defeat the evil black sock nearest
out your space suits I
oh yeah I got him I think I got him he's
down
shoot him what it's 10:00 what is he
doing trying to play drums to midnight
make me kill him I'll never fall that
I'll never fall for that again damn it
what is happy at he got me that's
awesome
very creative and I feel like that one
really fit the theme as well
number five is PewDiePie's Paradise
Island which unfortunately I played
already in an episode that I already
wish I haven't uploaded but I love this
game this game is amazing I want to show
it off real quick but I'm otherwise I'm
gonna play it in another episode so it
feels pointless for me to do it again
just love this style I love the graphics
I love the music I love everything
overpowered I never played it's made by
ASCII ASCII can I ask a if I can play
skee let's play it looks really cool Wow
no no but stop oh it's one of these it's
one of these huh it runs so nice oh my
god it's wonderful but Jesus Christ I'm
dying no thanks hey Gramps welcome to
the pitch of true heroes thanks and
expecting you here oh thanks sort of
appeals have come through here Carnera
hunka the challenges of this dungeon
okay claim one of its many treasures
okay any determined warriors and
adventurers all of them but I'm not
determining warrior Avery what's your
name what if I uh see Bob Larry Moore
its gave me sexy I'm just kidding ah yes
more a fine name now let's get going
time is running out alright well that's
gonna go anyway there used to be an
elevator here it's just a quick climb up
though you can make it right
yeah totally bready totally prosky nope
never mind ouch
oh you can see my whole body there too
oh my god this game is amazing
holy [ __ ] ah ah there we go oh god oh
god
ah oh you kawaii son of a [ __ ] whatta
hell I was so happy
stop what am I supposed to do come on
alright I'll just go through oh hey I
hate you oh why did it take heaven shame
the fries and save the world what the
hell is this what nothing happens
how can they of me this is so quick is
he ok we take the jr. Thanks
oh no oh god oh god oh god they're
everywhere how am I gonna do that
oh my lord oh my aw how in the heaven oh
I need to go up there okay I get it
don't push me buddy
super Shirley oh I had it I had it
Oh
oh if you are a pure spirit you will be
able to cross it to your goal well
theoretically anyway meditate with Si
and focus your spirit then release and
fly across the chasm I thought it well I
always thought it was chasm I'm charging
my fire bill boom great god damn it ah
heroes just can't jump as good these
days
Oh what the [ __ ] three hours later I'm
dead I'm alive
Oh
and I would oh my god
what whoa level 100 beach Oh what's up
what's up get to beat the [ __ ] out of
everything
[ __ ] yo I'm level hundred [ __ ] is
this game hard not hard 11 like coolness
yeah
warning okay I'll cut it's a boss what
DX Lords any theas Mak yes so much
health 100 that was it
hahahahahaha oh my god more you did it
you magnificant here magnificent hero
but we need to escape quickly this place
is about to blow
alright
and we did it hey Kenny [ __ ] you kitty
ha ha ha cat saved I shave the cat
you're welcome kitty oh my god this game
blew me away I'm so impressed fun to
play run smoothly like it's detailed
it's funny and it was a nice fitting jam
I loved it
that was amazing great job I'm super
impressed
dance dance PewDiePie and I like the
sound of that q e a D man oh my god
again yes no he changed what the [ __ ] I
danced for three seconds alright let's
do this keep dancing keep changing keep
changing Oh uh-huh uh-huh this is how we
do it in the poet pad town yay this is
really how I dance I don't know how they
captured it so well like it's quite
impressive beard path best mix of a song
ever made oh god it gets hard oh that's
what you say uh oh my god oh my god what
is happening oh god now 45 seconds okay
this part man I can't
oh god no one more time maybe um I like
my outfit by the way sir fabulous as
always
awk everytime 47 dammit I guess I'm not
as good as dancing as I am fabulous
hello that game dance Sanskrit apply.you
versus check it out this hair though
don't know what to [ __ ] to say about
that but Wilson Almeida made it Thank
You Wilson Almeida
ah here we are kid vs. school select
your level what I'll get him am i puking
what am i doing
I completely miss the story of this game
oh no not school okay what what am i
puked out ow
did I die I'll God ruler I'm stuck I'm
[ __ ] stuck how am i throwing up this
much I love it please teach me senpai
No hey I yes
thanks I'm so proud of myself I want to
thank my bros and my hoes
yeah those skill spray just skills bra
ahh bra bra okay okay all right here we
go here we go here we go here we go here
we go oh nothing's wrong with me sorry
there is something wrong with anyone who
sings that song Oh God not to ruler I'm
a lad
okay of coz yay Hey oh my god that is
the best thing I've seen in my life I
got to penetrate the pest test I like
that game got through what all I have to
throw up on the test that makes even
more stains watch out for me basket buzz
here we go
yes okay I can't die now I'm gonna be so
pissed
oh my god I'm gonna be so happy fight oh
no no the roof oh my god
school is speeding me hard right now all
right I hate you you sneaky son I don't
trust anything at this point
yes roma say
yeah actually really enjoyable to play
after a while once you get good like I
am in every game ever I've got oh my god
these skills Brett do use [ __ ] seat
never mind
cool idea I played well and the kid has
a green shirt and finally we're at the
winner Lord of hard hello my friend this
is a taste level to see what kind of
things you can do
I invited some friends here to say hi to
them a maybe ok all right that's cool
that's cool
what am i doing no one knows I guess I
should eat him/her there you go you're
mine now
oh my god I'm controlling us that's
awesome
kill all the humans and it's gone No
good job I wonder what will happen if
it's green goo Alice it green goo would
come friends we just want to party with
you yes we love to party party party
party come on man
be green with us hey that's a cool this
really cool game I was not disappoint
come on babe don't be shy damn it
oh god no my some be friends oh there we
go it's over you're dead hey how's
everyone doing yeah you're all gonna die
I like the style of the game - I never
thought it would be so satisfying to
just patrol an army of zombies it's kind
of genius actually oh my God look how
many we are this was awesome
plants all brains
he looks all frames commands I wanna
beat the game at least last level baby
well this is his madness time's up 9 9 9
are you kidding me alright well that was
lord of horde I really like that game -
I love all these games super proud of
everyone participating I love how this
whole turnout I I'm just I'm lost for
words this is this whole thing has been
amazing thanks to everyone we're not
gonna end it there though but we're
gonna end this episode there so thank
you thank you thank you thank you bros
for watching there's like if you enjoyed
bros and as always stay awesome bros